let's try adding a new property to the
blue object now of course when we go to
do a look-up on a property that got
copied onto the blue object we get the
value we'd expect which was originally
copied over from gold and it's no
different for the property that was
added manually by our code as with the
gold object a lookup for a property that
isn't available on blue should result in
undefined let's make another replica of
the gold object this time using a
different strategy to achieve that
similarity rather than copying the
properties over one by one the idea
would be to give the ROS object some
linkage to the gold object such that
whenever a requested property can't be
found on Rose it uses gold as sort of a
fallback source of properties the object
create function can create objects for
you that have this delegation lookup
feature just pass in your desired
fallback object and it produces a new
object the delegates failed lookups to
the fallback you can still interact with
this special new object in the same way
you would any other regular object but
when you ask that object for a property
that can't be found directly on the
object itself it does something rather
interesting the lookup falls through up
the chain to the prototype object so
what do you think will get logged in
this situation